in 2022 Science magazine selected NASA's
new space telescope jwst as its
breakthrough of the year after a
successful launch and a near-perfect
unfolding and commissioning process the
data coming in are already giving us a
much clearer picture of the cosmos than
we've ever seen
but there is a lot of groundbreaking
science last year in the lab the field
and even in Congress here are a few
other advances that made 2022 a big year
for science
thank you
[Music]
2021's breakthrough of the year was ai's
ability to predict protein structures
this year AI continued to get creative
from designing novel proteins to writing
computer code that could solve numerical
problems on the visual front text to
image models like Dolly 2 generated
intricate and captivating images in the
coming years humans will continue to use
AI as a tool to innovate and create
NASA's double asteroid redirection test
crashed a spacecraft into a little Moon
called dimorphos permanently altering
its orbit this was the first ever trial
of the planetary defense strategy that
could be used if we ever detected an
asteroid on a collision course with
Earth
using medical records from millions of
U.S military service people researchers
found that an infection by the
Epstein-Barr virus a common herpes virus
raised the risk of developing multiple
sclerosis 32-fold another team of
scientists discovered that one of
epstein-barr's proteins can trick the
immune system into attacking neurons
these new discoveries could spur efforts
to develop anti-viral drugs to treat Ms
and raise the possibility that vaccines
could prevent it altogether
[Music]
researchers have extracted 2 million
year old DNA Snippets from northern
Greenland doubling what was thought to
be the shelf life of DNA analysis of the
environmental DNA or e-dna paints a
picture of a lush Forest unlike anything
that exists today
Edna from sites with similar
preservation could provide new insights
into other arctic areas where fossils
are sparse
figuring out how the Black Death left
its mark on survivors has been difficult
but by studying the ancient DNA of 500
people buried in Europe before during
and after the Black Death researchers
found that survivors had Gene variants
that boosted their immunity to the
fleborne bacterium that causes the
plague one protective variant persists
in some Europeans today but it also puts
these individuals at a higher risk for
developing autoimmune diseases
large-scale clinical trials of two
vaccines against respiratory syncytial
virus or RSV can safely protect the two
groups hardest hit by this common
infection infants and the elderly RSV
vaccine development was derailed for
decades after a trial 50 years ago made
infections worse but the new vaccines
use advanced technology to trigger a far
better antibody response
[Music]
foreign
of the French Antilles researchers
discovered a bacterium up to two
centimeters long five thousand times
longer than a typical microbe unlike
other bacterial cells the margarita
magnifica packages its DNA into sacs
called pepins its unique internal
structure could represent a transitional
form between eukaryotes and prokaryotes
researchers in China showed that a new
strain of perennial rice can survive
year after year and produce crop yields
similar to regular seasonally planted
rice the new strain called perennial
rice 23 is a cross between Asian rice
and a wild rice from Africa perennial
food crops like this could make feeding
the world far less expensive and
labor-intensive
for the first time the U.S passed a law
that could substantially reduce climate
emissions the climate Provisions in the
inflation reduction act will provide 369
billion dollars over 10 years to support
renewable energy and nuclear power
facilitate the shift to electric
vehicles and fund research on Industrial
emissions reductions
while critics say it still isn't enough
to meet globally established targets it
marks the biggest legislative step the
U.S has ever taken to slow global
warming
that wraps up our list of major
advancements for 2022 and our staff is
already looking at the year ahead new
treatments launches and legislation are
just a few of the areas to watch that
will push the boundaries of Science in
2023
[Music]